katie kate
terminierte hercules
keine ahnung das war finish
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys wels
ihr wisst ja dass wir vor kurzem in
lappland waren mit murat zusammen und
für alle die es vielleicht nicht ganz
mitgekriegt haben wir waren in lappland
und zwar auf einem event das war von big
green egg geplant und wir haben dort
einfach zwei drei schöne tage verbracht
mit murat wird dürften da zu gast sein
und love land war für uns wirklich so
eine reise muss ich sagen ich hätte
glaube ich nie lappland auf einem
reiseziel gehabt finnland sowieso weil
es einfach für uns eine ecke war die wir
nie so richtig auf dem schirm hatten und
es war richtig richtig schön es hat sich
angefühlt wie irgendwie zwei wochen weil
wir total viel erlebt haben und wir
haben dort einmal einen eintopf gegessen
da waren wir extrem lange unterwegs bei
- also der erste tag nach minus 10 grad
der zweite tag bei minus 35 grad da ist
wirklich das gesicht eingefroren draußen
aber es wird trotzdem richtig schön weil
es einfach so eine schöne trockene kälte
war so ein hammer mäßiger ausflug und
falls ihr noch nie in finnland war es
ist wirklich eine reise wert und wie
gesagt haben wir am zweiten tag einen
eintopf gegessen so eine finnische lachs
suppe und die war der hammer ich meine
wenn man dann sowieso so ein bisschen
verfroren ist und draußen die ganze zeit
wandert und schneemobil fährt und wir
waren da noch eisfischen wir uns
zumindest versucht wir haben keinen
fisch gefangen aber der versuch war es
wert und wie gesagt diese lachs suppe
möchte ich heute zu bereiten die zutaten
sind auch ganz einfach und auch die
zubereitung ist ganz einfach und die war
echt echt wirklich sehr sehr lecker
falls sie das ganze vegetarisch
zubereiten wollte einfach den lachs
weglassen ansonsten muss ich sagen dass
es diese suppe auch am nächsten tag x
mit rentier gab also es gab auch ein
rentier eindruck der war ungefähr gleich
hier gibt bei uns in deutschland
vielleicht dazu deswegen dachte ich mir
machen wir jetzt den lachs eintopf ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten dafür nehme
ich eine stange porree karotten
dann ne zitrone darf bio sein und
umgespritzt auf jeden fall etwas butter
600 gramm kartoffeln entweder vorwiegend
festkochend oder mädels kochen ich habe
ich schon mal lorbeerblättern frischen
lachs 500 gramm oder tiefgekühlten lachs
etwas dill
gemüsebrühe dann habe ich jetzt einfach
wasser und selbstgemachte gemüsebrühe
sahne zum abschmecken und hier noch salz
und pfeffer beim pre werde ich jetzt
auch nur die hälfte brauchen und da ist
es aber so ich war sowieso gleich das
gemüse bevor ich es dann an berater also
zu tun hab ich schon gewaschen die
karotten schälen gleich und auch die
kartoffeln und beim porträt mache ich es
tatsächlich so weil der ja wirklich oft
sehr sandig ist weil er eben diese
verschiedenen schichten hat dann nehme
ich nur außen diese dunkelgrünen blätter
erst mal weg die sind nämlich ein
bisschen bitter und die könnt ihr aber
auch weil die eben viel geschmack haben
könnt ihr sie auch verwenden um
gemüsebrühe zu machen also ich würde
jetzt nicht dass hieraus nehmen das
würde ich schon wegschneiden aber jetzt
gerade das schöne dunkelgrüne das
schneide ich dann gern weg und macht
gemüsebrühe draus und deswegen habe ich
auch hier
diese passte weil das meine
selbstgemacht gemüsebrühe passt ist und
die könnt ihr einfach zubereiten aus
gemüse resten gemüse noch mit rein
gewürze mit rein und da findet ihr
einfach auf meinem kanal schauen das
rezept dazu also guckt da gerne mal rein
jetzt seht ihr so sieht der pole aus und
ich schneide denn jetzt erst mal ich
brauche auch nur die hälfte tatsächlich
aber ich schneidet alles und halt wir es
später und kann dann die hälfte einfach
etwas anderes machen
[Musik]
jetzt sieht man hier auch ganz gut dass
der wirklich relativ schmutzig ist
[Musik]
packte den am besten in so eine
salatschleuder was stehen da drin und
steuert ihn trocken so scheitert man
auch den ganzen samt raus
[Musik]
welche die kartoffeln und karotten
jetzt könnt ihr hier die karotten und
die kartoffeln fein würfeln ich muss
sagen wenn ich das jetzt so privat ohne
kamera machen würde wenn ich eine
größere menge habe dann nehme ich auch
gern meinen würfel schneider von der can
wurde oder von der kitchenaid aber so
könnte es ja auch ganz einfach und
schnell würfeln
[Musik]
mindest alles gewürfelt ist habt ihr
eigentlich die gröbste arbeit schon
erledigt ist nehmen wir die butter und
erhitzt sie in einem topf ich nehme
jetzt bankkreisen top darin da ich immer
ganz gerne gerichte was sie auch machen
könnte und gericht auch draußen auf dem
grill zubereiten zum beispiel im big
green egg wenn ihr möchtet ansonsten
einfach im sport abnehmen oder einen
tiefen anderen topf und jetzt wird alles
schön angebraten das heißt mit der
butter auch gerne direkt den lauch ich
muss sagen ich glaube ich damit doch die
ganze party stange ja weil so viel ist
dann doch nicht sonst ist das wenig
das wasser schön weil wir da in lappland
draußen dann am feuer saßen und dann
haben wir so diesen eintopf gegessen das
war schon schön und ich war so naiv ich
hab meiner wasser eine wasserflasche mit
einem rucksack die war natürlich dann
einige frauen kennt ja auch mitdenken
können und dann hat man so diesen warmen
eintopf und das war dann schon schön
aber man durfte also länger als fünf
minuten konnte man nicht essen weil dann
ist ja alles festgefroren also ich jetzt
einfach schön 2 3 minuten anbraten
[Musik]
hat sich hier gebe ich jetzt das gemüse
noch rein zum mit anbraten und
gerne auch schon mal die lorbeerblätter
die dürfen auch mit rein für den
geschmack und auch eine zitronenscheibe
also einfach die zitrone halbieren
deswegen sollten die eben auch nicht
gespritzt seien die schale zum verzehr
geeignet sein die kerne nämlich mal raus
und dann kommt es hier auch mit rein
kurz mit anbraten
[Musik]
und dann gern mit der brühe aufgießen
und wie gesagt nämlich ganz einfach die
selbstgemachte brühe
und dann könnt ihr nämlich hier noch mit
salz und pfeffer abschmecken und
das ganze dann schön aufkochen lassen
und einfach mal durchgehen lassen also
so dass die kartoffeln und die karotten
wirklich fast gar sind und da kümmere
ich mich nämlich so lange um den lachs
da kommt nur ganz zum schluss mit rein
da braucht er nicht so lange und wenn
man den jetzt direkt mit dazu gibt dann
mit den lachs jetzt schon mit dazu gibt
dann zerfällt er nämlich beim kochen
deswegen erstmal karotten kartoffeln
kann
wenn das gericht dann gar ist also die
kartoffel und so kurz vor
perfektem gar ergebnis sind dann könnt
ihr euch jetzt schon mal um den lachs
kümmern und wie gesagt nimmt jetzt
entweder frischen lachs oder einfach
tiefgefrorenen lachs den kann man
nämlich immer im gefrierfach lassen und
hatten immer auf vorrat dann einfach
auch schön fein würfeln
und dann wird alles eigentlich nur noch
fertig gestellt und das gericht ist
schon fertig also es wirklich schon 30
minuten gericht muss ich sagen weil es
jetzt auch gar nicht so lange garen
musste weil die kartoffeln eben auch
schön fein gewürfelt sind
[Musik]
könnte hier auch noch den sinn fein
schneiden
das nimmt ihr hier am besten zuerst
einmal die zitrone raus und die
lorbeerblätter die sind auch hier intro
dass die später nicht auf dem teller
landen
ich finde es jetzt kommt mit regal
furcht und später raus dann könnt ihr
nämlich die sahne aufgießen und das
ganze noch mal kurz erwärmen und jetzt
ist aber eigentlich wichtig dass das
ganze nicht mehr kocht damit einfach der
lack so schön gar ziehen kann und eben
nicht verkocht und zerfällt das ist halt
jetzt schon wichtig
dass ich alles schön mit rein
dann muss ich eigentlich schon denn
murat probieren lassen und er hat sie
auch vor ort gegessen ob interessiert
dann genauso gut schmeckt will mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt hier schön einrühren und
dann darf das alter noch kurz gar ziehen
[Musik]
skater terminiert der herkules
keine ahnung das war finish jetzt haben
sie wahrscheinlich gerade mehrere finden
gerade vom balkon geworfen nachdem sie
das gehört haben
die nicht ist eine sprache die verstehe
ich ja es ist wie bei vielen sprachen da
hört man also wissen was raus aber ich
finde am besten ist es holländisch es
richtig heißen mix zwischen englischen
deutsch ist aber aber finish ist eine
sprache da komme ich da komme es zu
lernen mit wahrscheinlich sehr sehr
schwer sein wobei für die finden die
wahrscheinlich auch die deutsche sprache
sehr schwierig wir haben ja die artikel
der die das und meisten sprachen gibt es
ja gar nicht ja es ist schwierig also
ich habe jetzt hier für uns die lachs
suppe gekommen ist übrigens nicht finden
wirklich ein gast mit ich zwar sei
mäßigkeit sehr sehr gastfreundliches
wohl unglaublich gastfreundlich und weil
es so kalt ich wusste ich nicht ob sie
freundlich sind oder einfach einen im
tee haben keine ahnung wer die waren
echt super und diesel ab sofort diesen
topf ich würde es eher als eintopf
bezeichnen also ich finde das ist
eigentlich eine suppe oder eintopf und
das haben wir ja dort vor ort gegessen
und meiner meinung nach sein rezept was
auf jeden fall definitiv in jede schnee
hütte gehört also in jede schnee hütte
gehört wenn es kalt ist sowieso wenn es
warm ist auch lecker aber das besondere
war wirklich diese extreme kälte und du
hast es gegessen es war warm und und sk
die pflege es war mein traum lagerfeuer
draußen da war sogar noch ein brot dabei
dass man auch glauben finnischen
spezialität das problem war nur dass
draußen wirklich mal alles eingefroren
ist alsmann hat wegen dieses brot
gegessen aber das wird das steinhart
weil es einfach gefroren war und dann
haben wir das irgendwann einfach auch so
stöcke aufgespießt und über das
lagerfeuer kalten wieso marshmallows und
die hatten auch so sind schnecken und
diese zehn strecken man auch gefroren
und die mussten wir am lagerfeuer
grillen dass sie warm werden aber ich
glaube jetzt ganz sicher ein paar sachen
habe ich gegessen bekanntlich eigentlich
schon fast von ikea ich hielt sich gegen
eine finnische spezialitäten aber es war
sehr okay lass ich sag immer
sagt dass die reise dahin das war auch
also da waren ja auch viele viele frauen
also so görtz drucken die dahin gereist
sind 50 der geburtstag am ein flugzeug
sehen zwar schon ganz cool und wie
schmeckt er schmeckt eins zu eins wieder
wirklich eins wo ich gemerkt habe du
hast ein bisschen mehr drin ja aber das
ist geschmackssache
nur der den märkten bisschen stärker
aber die den ist auch kurz ein bisschen
also ich kann wenn man denn mag dann
haut ruhig gerne mehr reine nicht so mag
dann ein bisschen vorsichtiger damit
oder lassen den weg und nimmt gerne auch
andere zutaten dafür wie findest du
schnelles rezept 30 minuten rezept ich
gehe ja also mit ist super und auch
finnland als reiseland stand niemals auf
unserer agenda das war echt zu fall
wunderschön ich würde es jedes mal
wieder machen
also ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachkochen probiert gerne mal aus wiechs
dann können wir das ganze auch
vegetarisch zu bereiten und eigentlich
sogar vegan wenn ihr dann eben im
veganen zahnersatz nimmt aber so weiß
jetzt auch egal so weiß mit lachs und so
wie wir es eben im ort gegessen haben
oder ich finds echt gut frühestens mit
zitronen mit zitronensaft abgeschmeckt
salz pfeffer hätte ich mehr war grüße an
alle finisher zuschauer dabei und bin
ich hoffe ich geantwortet habe auf eure
kommentare dann war das will ich ein
google übersetzer hatte und ich finde
ich kann nur so in ihm bei schon jetzt
habe ich auch nicht abgekauft wir
bestimmt also bis zum nächsten raum ein
schönes abendessen
[Musik]
wir sitzen ja gerade am lagerfeuer und
wir essen grad kartoffelsack suppe
schmeckt
so kalt denn es mir so kalt
[Musik]